Let's first have a look at the output.
You see that with rates of 20,000 and 50,000 tons per year, we do not seem to be over fishing.
However, with rates of 100,000 and 200,000 tons per year,
we clearly are over fishing, fish go extinct.
The line of code that actually implements the forward Euler method
is produced straightforward.
The harder part is to stop harvesting and this solution is as follows--
we check whether or not the amount of fish for the next step is equal to zero or negative.
If so, we set a flag that tells us whether I should be using zero
for the amount of fishing in all upcoming steps.
Note that you cannot simply check whether the amount of fish for the next step
is exactly equal to zero--that's probably not going to happen.